President Putin didn't have very much to
say about the war directly in his
Victory Day speeches The Narrative is
the same which is this is all about
NATO's long-term aggression against the
Russian people but he had very little to
announce about the war itself partly
because we suspect it's Dawning on him
that it isn't going very well he began
by trying to seize Kiev in 72 hours that
went completely wrong then he tried to
grab the cities in the north and east of
the country that didn't work either and
so now he's concentrated all of his
forces in the southeast of the country
in the south in order to grab territory
and this battle of the donbass has been
building up for a couple of weeks it is
now properly joined over the last couple
of days and we can see how this battle
is beginning to go there are pros and
cons for both sides in maliopol the
Russians have marry a poll but not the
other style steel works and so
symbolically the fact that ukrainians
are still holding out at avastal is
still a problem for President Putin
the Russians have made some gains at
papasana they've pushed harder papasna
and they've actually forced ukrainians
to pull back so the ukrainians have gone
back to what they say are prepared
defensive positions they've lost a bit
of their perimeter there but further
north at isium which is a very important
Northern anchor for this whole Russian
offensive going southwards at isium the
ukrainians are attacking from the west
and they're making that Northern anchor
rather less secure that gives the
Russians something to worry about more
important at khaki further north
Ukraine's Second City the ukrainians are
attacking in the North and the Northeast
they've pushed Russian Field Artillery
out of range which is a relief of course
to the city of kharkiv but more than
that it threatens the communication line
between Belgrade in Russia car given izm
that's a very important communication
line and it complicates the problem and
so what the ukrainians have done is to
give the Russians something else to
worry about in their own rear area
that's a pretty good tactic
we'll see how it goes the ukrainians
keep issuing uh video footage and
photographs of destroyed Russian
equipment of course these are Ukrainian
claims
but the fact is that more than three and
a half thousand of these claims have
been independently verified by external
observers photographically it appears
that the Russians have lost about three
times as much heavy equipment as the
ukrainians and at least twice as many
troops
and so this battle is not going terribly
well at the moment for any of them
of course battles are inherently
unpredictable but the fact is if I was
looking at this from either Kiev or
Moscow at the moment
I'd be a lot happier if I was President
zielinski than If I Was President Putin
but the next two or three weeks will be
absolutely critical